[Música]
qué es hacer las cosas a la mexicana
de botepronto y a como esta cultura nos
ha forzado a entender pudiéramos decir
que significa hacer las cosas mal o a
medias
fáciles al aventón
chafí está hacer que las cosas salgan
porque tienen que salir no porque
verdaderamente se quiere hacer las cosas
bien
significa hacerlo menos con el menor
esfuerzo posible
eso es lo que nuestra cultura nos ha
forzado a entender
nos agregamos a nosotros mismos día con
día y lamentablemente parece ser que hoy
en día está bien hablar mal de un
mexicano
por el simple hecho de ser un mexicano
piénsenlo así es como si cada vez que
hablamos mal de un mexicano nos diéramos
un balazo en el pie
es como si cada vez que habláramos mal
de un mexicano nos pusiéramos piedritas
en el camino para que algún otro
mexicano se tropieza con ellas
es un cuento de nunca acabar y es un
ciclo que se repite se repite y se
repite que no nos permite avanzar
pensando todo esto y reflexionando en
ello me pregunto
porque hablamos tan mal de nosotros
mismos
será que hablar mal de otro mexicano o
de los mexicanos automáticamente nos
exenta de todo lo malo
qué nos pasó
en qué momento comenzamos a hablar tan
mal de nosotros mismos
pero
la pregunta más importante aquí es
lo que decimos que somos
mexicano es un ser bastante particular
es un ser bastante único un individuo
con una capacidad tremenda para resolver
cualquier situación con creatividad
significa
hacer las cosas con el mayor esfuerzo
posible
significa caer en el bache y salir
adelante resolviendo cualquier situación
de formas inesperadas poniéndole el
mayor de los esfuerzos para mí eso es
hacer las cosas a la mexicana
para mí el mexicano es una persona que
hace las cosas con empeño dedicación
esfuerzo
que sabe hacer las cosas bien
sabemos hacer las cosas bien sabemos
encontrar soluciones efectivas
a cualquier situación compleja pero
sobre todo
el mexicano a diferencia de cualquier
otra persona cuenta con una resiliencia
envidiable
para resolver cualquier adversidad que
se le pone de frente
ejemplo de lo que les digo lo vemos de
diario en las calles de todo méxico
donde las personas nunca paran por
ninguna situación
donde las soluciones siempre se buscan
y siempre se encuentran
ejemplo de esto lo vimos también hace
casi un año
en el mes de septiembre pasado
cuando méxico fue capaz de unirse en uno
solo dejando de lado cualquier
distinción para apoyar a nuestros
hermanos en la ciudad de mexico que
estaban sufriendo las catástrofes del
sismo
ejemplo de que hacemos las cosas bien y
de personajes que hacen las cosas bien
sobran
guillermo del toro por ejemplo
quien con poco presupuesto para su
película la forma del agua
logro se las ingenió para crearlas y
logró ganar así el premio al de mejor
director
al de mejor película al de mejor diseño
de producción y al de mejor banda sonora
eso es hacer las cosas a la mexicana
tenemos por ejemplo también a javier
hernández quien actualmente es el mayor
goleador de la selección mexicana y
logró lo que pocos creían posible y lo
que muchos le dijeron que no podía hacer
jugar en las grandes ligas europeas y
poner en alto el nombre de nuestro país
eso es hacer las cosas a la mexicana
o como guillermo gonzález camarena quien
fue una de las mentes más deslumbrantes
del siglo 20
y creo la televisión a color
eso es hacer las cosas a la mexicana
o como tatiana bilbao quien recibió uno
de los cinco premios globales de
arquitectura sostenible
que se le entregan a los mejores
arquitectos comprometidos con el medio
ambiente
eso es hacer las cosas a la mexicana
o como luís enrique velasco
quien actualmente trabaja en la nasa y
forma parte del equipo marte 2020
qué es un equipo que viajará al planeta
marte a descubrir más sobre ese planeta
mexicanos poniendo los pies sobre otro
planeta
eso
es hacer las cosas a la mexicana
ahora bien
con decir que hacer las cosas a la
mexicana no me refiero a que todo dentro
del país sea color de rosa
que no haya problemas que tengamos que
resolver
sin exactamente todo lo contrario y
precisamente me refiero a eso
en el país existen innumerables
problemas desconfianza en nuestras
instituciones
una situación de inseguridad tremenda
que lamentablemente hoy por hoy vemos
como algo normal
vemos como algo normal amanecer con
cuatro homicidios
vemos como algo normal tener 60 millones
de pobres
cuando no lo es
una paupérrima calidad educativa y una
ciudad
que se cae a pedazos
pero el mayor problema que tenemos los
mexicanos no es ninguno de los
anteriores
el gran problema que tenemos la gran
mayoría de los mexicanos no todos es
no aceptar el hecho de que todos los
problemas que mencioné entre otros son
nuestra responsabilidad
aventarnos la pelotita de a ver quién
tiene la culpa
ese es el gran problema que enfrentamos
los mexicanos
y hacer las cosas a la mexicana es
exactamente todo lo contrario
es ser conscientes
de que transformar este país y de que
rescatar este país es tarea de todos
no de uno solo
es ser conscientes
de que nuestras acciones son
multiplicadoras
y que depende de nosotros definir el
rumbo
de ese efecto multiplicador
hay que ser conscientes como bien lo
dice mi papá
de que todo lo que nos pasa
lo provocamos o lo permitimos
es así de sencillo
en la película 'los increíbles' 2
la trama de la película se centra en la
familia park
y de cómo está de cómo esta familia
lucha por reintegrarse al tejido social
pues el gobierno ha declarado ilegales a
los super
además los pocos super que quedan en esa
ciudad ven los problemas resolverse de
lejos
no porque no quieran
sino porque el gobierno ha declarado
ilegales a los super eso es a grandes
rasgos la película
por mas burgos que esto suene
y por más infantil que esto les parezca
méxico y la ciudad de los increíbles dos
comparten una gran similitud y una gran
diferencia
la gran similitud que tenemos los
mexicanos con la ciudad de los
increíbles 2
es que aquí vemos los problemas
resolverse de lejos y la gran diferencia
es que en méxico sobran los super
sobran los super mexicanos que cuentan
con dos poderes esenciales
y ser ciudadanos de tiempo completo
y 2 hacer las cosas a la mexicana
eso es un poder que ninguna otra persona
tiene más que los mexicanos
pero adivinen qué
nuestro super
están escondidos
señoras y señores
los super en méxico no están prohibidos
los super en mexico no son ilegales
en méxico sobran los super mexicanos y
son cada uno de ustedes
rescatar esta ciudad y rescatar este
país es tarea de todos
y si nos quedamos con los brazos
cruzados esperando que alguien más lo
resuelva nos quedaremos igual
quiero agradecer de sobremanera
a mi súper favoritos
a mis papás
deben de estar por aquí
quiero agradecer a mis súper favoritos
gracias papá y gracias mamá por
enseñarme que en méxico aún existen
súpers y que están entre nosotros
gracias por enseñarme de que ese efecto
multiplicador lo tenemos cada uno de
nosotros y que la responsabilidad esté
en uno
gracias infinitas
eso es mi idea
eso es lo que propongo
ciudadanos de tiempo completo que hagan
las cosas a la mexicana
no es una solución mágica
pero si es una diferente
y rescatar este país
es tarea de todos
soy erick lópez y esta familia de sol
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]